thrash-metal combined with a Middle
Eastern sound that's black young the
Lebanese band competed in this year's
Bakken metal battle the famous hard rock
festival is just a six hour flight from
their home in Beirut but it feels like
another world
that's the real metal culture that we're
living here it's it's as real as you can
get I guess I mean we've all dreamed of
just attending vagon and now we're
playing that's awesome black young are
true metal veterans who founded their
band 20 years ago and all four still
have full-time day jobs for black young
Bakken open-air was a chance to
celebrate along with the festival's
metal scene forced like it's very well
known in Lebanon and the fact that
rockin real discovered us like we they
know now there's the metal scene it made
the people in the medicine in Lebanon
extremely happy black young hail from
Beirut the capital of Lebanon home to
about six million people the country has
been shaped by both Christian and Muslim
influences
although metal is anything but
mainstream in Lebanon black young have
stayed the course they're one of the few
local metal bands who've made an
international name for themselves
for such a small country I think when
you make a concert and like a gig in a
club and you can a pub and you get 200
people I mean that's good and then when
we take make a festival we got between
800 and 1000 I mean that's good for such
a small scene at Vulcan metal battle
Blackcomb played before an audience of
5000 the band incorporates a traditional
goblet drum from Lebanon's musical
heritage
I was impressed by the drumming it was
really I think it's really good yeah
fantastic we're really proud that you
here the jury was also impressed black
iam took third place in the 2015 medal
battle the metal scene in my country
finally get to be recognized as
legitimate that we really have metal
band and strong bands we really want
before the results were announced you
know and that's at set so really it's a
plus that we've scored third place among
really great bands from all over the
world
for black young the strong showing at
buckin metal battle also has another
dimension with any luck the
international recognition will make it a
bit easier to be a metalhead
in Lebanon
you